hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well emotion versus
traditional throughout history
now are there exceptions to this yeah I
can think of some really important
exceptions going all the way back into
Western you know the early Western
civilization how many of you read The
Odyssey remember all those passages
where Odysseus is crying that really
struck me because I you know I grew up
in a household word boys didn't cry and
you expect to be tough and all that and
here you have this guy who is one of the
toughest warriors of ancient Greece not
only one of the toughest one of the
smartest I'm inspected mobile people
down and he's you know a king of his own
little island and he's in charge of all
these men and when his men die he
grieves them he cries as he's rowing as
a matter of fact it's not just him the
rest of his crew are all they're all
crying together you know it's not the
case that all men throughout history
have never expressed
shins or anything like that but healthy
is onto something she says we're looking
at moral theory we're not just looking
at literary stuff the moral theory would
have been the main moral theories in the
modern era well the two biggest ones
have been on the one hand sort of Conch
and deontology and on the other hand
something like utilitarianism and it
doesn't necessarily have to be you know
Bentham's utilitarianism it could be
what we call rational choice theory
which gets used in economics and in
business in some other context like that
and it doesn't know me to be constant
ology it could be some other Duty based
conception but the idea is either you
have duty and you recognize that Duty
and it doesn't matter how you feel about
it what matters is you do the duty
because it's your duty and if you feel
bad in doing it because it goes against
your emotions or your desires not even
oh you're really doing it don't you now
you can be sure that you're doing the
right thing the other possibility is
well your desire is your emotions they
count for something but you have to you
know be rational about it you have to
calculate this you have to take
everybody's emotions and desires into
consideration and then you have to have
this you know sort of grand calculus
scheme and and figure out which is going
to benefit them the most and in both
cases what ends up happening is either
for your cons with can't you have reason
and then you have emotion or desire and
when you want to do get rid of that and
just focus on reason right categorical
imperative doesn't say anything about
see how you feel about it or how does
this actually make you feel says can you
will that this would be a universal law
of nature can you conceive of this
and it doesn't say would you like that
it says can you will it can you
rationally will so actually you should
put your emotions completely aside if
you're good conscious in some respects
what about utilitarianism well a motion
or a desire it's not you know totally
unacknowledged but it gets taken into
wreaths and reason should dominate it
reason should take it in and figure out
how to reconcile all these things do we
all you know have the same feelings or
emotions no we tend to became
self-interest that don't wait and you're
only going to get away from you know a
self-interested perspective if you take
a purely rational perspective Bentham
let's say or mill would say so in both
of these cases like she says emotion
gets gets sort of pushed aside and
emotion does get identified with the
female as opposed to man at least his
story so she says many feminist
philosophers would question whether the
reliance on abstract rules rather than
the adoption of more context with
respectful approaches and you know what
what does that mean that's a whole
that's kind of an abstract thing as the
entirety is she's she's bashing abstract
rules then she gives you this very
abstract sounding context respectful
approaches what what do you think that
would mean context respectful approaches
but it just means that it actually
focuses on the actual case that you're
in so when you are in a real moral
situation and all of you have been in
real situations right where you have to
choose between one friend and another or
you know decide whether to give the
money back that you found or you know
whether you should stay faithful to
somebody or cheat on them would given
the opportunity all these sorts of you
know protect the person who's being
bullied or join in or walk away all
those sorts of cases those are actual
context right do you have a
relationships with the people in those
case
usually is most of your moral life
concerned with absolute strangers who
you've never met before some of them
might be right you see somebody on the
side of the road they need some help you
don't know them do you stop and help
them but what's whilst you're more like
life like who are you engaged with who
are you making decisions about think
about your day-to-day life and the tough
choices you make cuz each one makes them
tough choices who is it who are you
involved parents right parents are often
the pain that you're aching you have to
figure out you're you guys are like
renegotiating your entire relationship
with them almost every time you go back
it's at least some of you you know it's
part of the process of becoming who who
you're on your way to being your friends
do all your friends have exactly the
same views or they all at the same moral
caliber - some of them try to get you to
do things that you probably shouldn't do
and others are like you've got to get
away from that person yeah you have you
are involved in in context specific
things those of you who are planning and
having kids later on kids are going to
pose you with all sorts of moral
problems that you have to solve and
oftentimes it's not just because of your
own kids fault it's because of their
connection with these other kids or
their teacher or you know what happened
with the bus driver or all these sorts
of things
those are all context specific so she's
saying rather than just relying on
abstract rules maybe we need some more
context respectful approaches and she
says women's experiences are
particularly important when it comes to
this she says women's experience of
moral problems seems to lead us to be
especially concerned with actual
relationships between embodied persons
with what those relationships seem to
require that's a good
point again that leads us to thinking
about an emotion when you actually have
a relationship with a person and it's
not just a purely business relationship
do you and having some sort of emotional
connection to them let's think about
some of the types of relationships that
they forget I'm going to actually pick
on the athletes here because they have
so many of you do you form an emotional
bond with your team your teammates in
any way or are they you could take them
or leave them
the hell with them we don't really know
what's your experience yeah you're going
through a common experience together
right and it's it's been the way it's
like going through boot camp going
through the practices you guys go
through or any of the other people that
go through similar things I mean anybody
who does ballet that's very grueling
that's good similar in many respects
very painful somebody's in your ballet
class and you go through with them
you're you should actually have some
emotional connections form if you don't
there's something wrong if you go
through life and you don't have any
feelings about the people who you've
worked with lived with engage in other
activities with that's that's you're
missing out on something you know one of
the best ways to start forming good
connections with other people that's why
it's so so particularly important to
have this this institution eating
together when you sit down at a table
with with another person or people over
and over again and just you know just
even share space and talk with them
you're not just being a body in the same
place there's an emotional connection
that develops isn't there that's one of
the best ways actually to overcome
prejudices or at least to start on the
path for that to get people who don't
who don't want to eat together actually
sitting and eating together because
inevitably they'll start
some things they haven't come so like
she says women are often inclined to
attend to rather than dismiss the
particularities of the context in which
moral problem arises and she says we
often pay attention to by this but we of
course she means women we often pay
attention to feelings of particular
feelings of empathy and caring so
there's a particular set of emotions
that she thinks are much more relevant
to moral life than say anger or sadness
or even necessarily joy empathy and
caring now it's a good question let's
let's go back to this again what it can
say about that sort of stuff did can't
think that you want to feel empathy
towards other people can you can you
require that if somebody is a moral duty
no even Ross on you you can't you can't
do that you can make you can say that
somebody has a duty to do something but
you can't say that they have a duty to
feel a certain way about it but isn't
empathy or carrying a feeling so are you
gonna get empathy or caring just by
coldly reasoning about things how do you
how do you get empathy how do you end up
sensing it within yourself what goes out
I mean some sort of emotion is involved
in any sort
the situation is something where
someone's yeah I thought Kant's theory
was stupid I don't I read your paper
I can't understand how you can't have
some sort of you know like yeah myself
I'm not a count you I I'm much more
sympathetic to this notion that we need
some sort of emotional basis to not just
emotion but some sort of emotional basis
integrated with reason to make sense out
of things and count represents one
particular way of looking at ethics that
you you know find you'd actually and
it's interesting have an emotional
reaction against it don't you yes such
as an intellectual reaction you would
actually feel this is wrong so how do
you feel a sense of what may be
repugnance might be the best way to
describe it
yeah what about utilitarianism
utilitarianism says well you know we
take these sort of things into
consideration and didn't Bentham say you
know we want people to have a motivation
of benevolence so they take pleasure in
other people's pleasure is that yet the
same thing as empathy
what's empathy like for you guys people
have been empathetic towards you at that
can you've been empathetic towards
others what does that mean
let's take a sort of a typical kind of
situation you come to me in my office
hours and what we'll use we'll use just
the example of the hurricane right
plenty of you have relatives who were
much more in the path of the hurricane
than we were here in the Hudson Valley
and so some of you have you know family
who may be the houses are damaged or
they got injured or something like that
could that distract you from the work
that you're supposed to do as a student
students fall behind sometimes in cases
like that yeah you guys are far enough
along you've seen that sort of thing
happen so you come to me then you say
dr. Stadler
and I know that you're a good student
cuz you've been like keeping on track
with the things and you've been you know
following along in class you say I'm
just you know I'm not I don't know
what's wrong with me
and I start talking with you and turns
out you know you're your dad got hurt in
the storm and you're really concerned
about it and let's say you have a couple
younger brothers or sisters to here the
oldest right so you're expected to be
like the strong one but you're doing
that from a distance and you're skyping
in and doing things like that now that
Internet has been restored but you you
know you're really it's bothering me
it's it's affecting not just this class
but your other classes and it's keeping
you from being able to buckle down and
get to get on with the work that you
need to do now I could just you know be
like a robot and say okay you've given
me the data now I process it okay you
get a pass all right but that's not what
you want is it I mean if you actually
come to my office hours to explain your
condition to me you're looking for
something more than that aren't you if I
would just add that sort of response
like okay here's a checklist I'm going
to rationally process this you qualify
for an extension for this how would you
feel where do you like that
that'd be a weird thing to do and there
may be a few professors who would act
like that I could think of something I
can what would it be like for me to be
empathetic what it mean just to say Oh
for you Oh what can I can I get you a
blankets you know or something like that
personal cookies I want you to feel
better is that is that empathy now that
that's that's kind of weird
sickly kind of I don't know what to call
it
well what's up does what's the thing in
the middle like emotionally you can't
professors who have cared about you
right well how can you tell what is it
like for you what I do what if your
experience is double yeah yeah and now
notice it's not just you know all mushy
gushy warm and fuzzy stuff he's they try
to work with you like you said in a
reasonable way doesn't mean that it
becomes all pure detached abstract
reason and they do it doesn't just have
to do with feeling it has to do with the
action too they try to work with him how
can you tell they're trying to work with
you
what does that feel like what does that
look like think about cases where you
guys needed a professor to work with you
like that what was it like
boy I bet every one of you has had in
some case like that come off at one time
or other maybe not here maybe in high
school or middle school what was it like
for you yeah that's an important thing
you're you're treated as not just as a
case but as a person so you they work
with you like you said at your pace why
well because you know it's your pace
it's not gonna do any good to say well
you ought to be over here being
empathetic means sort of understanding
the other person it's part of what we
call emotional intelligence emotional
intelligence is not just about managing
your own emotions it's not just about
realizing what other people are feeling
it's about being able to sort of take in
what they're feeling and make sense of
it as something that matters to you so
if I know pathetic towards your plight
that means that in some respect I care
about even though you're you know you're
you're a student and I you know may not
have any connection with you after the
class is over I have some feeling for
you as a person and your plight matters
to me and the way that you feel about it
matters to me the way that you're able
to perform or not perform matters to me
your your structure of motivation you
might say is something that enters into
my emotional life not dominating it that
would that would be that mushy gushy
stuff over here but allowing me to do
the kinds of action allow display of
care that give you what it is that you
need in order to to do better to feel
better to flourish ultimately how many
of you had like you've been in the ER or
had an operation or something
like that I know I've been in the are
many times non-stop
what does it like for for a doctor to be
empathetic or a nurse to be empathetic
what does that feel like to you as
opposed to somebody who's just doing
triage and getting you through there's
possible I mean I coming through the
field that I work in coming in Social
Work you know there's a whole sort of
that's a tough one to cuz what's the
main risk well the thing is in terms of
trying to be empathetic you it's about
being able to meet the person where
they're at yeah it's meaning it's not
bringing them to you but to go to them
and say okay where can I help you and
then allowing people to make one of our
course there's a self-determination
Dan take decisions for themselves and to
support those decisions and to help
guide the decision in a way that's going
to be beneficial to that to see things
from a point of view from their point of
view and to try to understand their
experience and you can address their
experience in a way that's going to be
beneficial yeah it's about asking you
know four questions into taking them you
know how am I feeling how can i you know
how how is this person feeling well me
people want what if the atmosphere how
do i best respond to that you know all
of those things come play come into play
when you try to to work with the clients
yeah and it's what perspective that
along with the feminist perspective that
that social work was used to be
empathetic yeah and in a fix it does it
takes work to has to practice yes yeah
well ask somebody but not not doing
what's actually right to the child and
that's what I was asking about the rest
welcome risk and but that's just as in
social word my job is not to make
decisions for you my job is to help you
make decisions with you that are going
to benefit you so I'm not saying - and
also since there's a lot of black and
white but there's also a lot of grey
like a woman or mother was had their
children taken away because of Education
of neglect
you know so okay well she's a bad mom
cuz I'm not sending her kids to school
well why isn't she sending her kids to
school it's because she doesn't have a
car is it because she doesn't have a job
it's because she's working til 3:00 in
the morning and they can't get up in the
morning it's a good business what are
the reasons for that you know so a lot
of times when we look at Social Work and
you look at people people make a
judgment here oh this is what it is and
that's why yeah as a social worker I
have to be apathetic and say okay one of
the reasons that this person is not
getting their kids to school I think you
know there are a lot of them yeah a lot
of that looks to be a little less amount
of emotion more a matter of like
processes of inquiry
you know figuring out why why are things
the case maybe emotion drives it to a
certain extent you say this person
actually matters so I'm going to care
enough to find out the reasons why but
this is this is a real tension let's go
on with this there's a few other things
I want
it was a good discussion she brings up
this idea of an ethics of care and she
says that an ethics of care needs to be
developed some think it should
since superseded what she's gonna call
an ethic of justice and we're going to
look at that a little bit more later
what would that look like
she says re-evaluates the place of
emotion of morality in two different
ways some think that morality requires
the development of moral emotions and so
this is a good thing to consider what
are moral emotions are there certain
emotions that matter more for moral life
than others we've already talked about
care and we talked about empathy she's
not going to talk about anger anger by
itself though we've discussed this quite
a bit why do people get angry they feel
that some moral wrong has been committed
either against themselves or against
somebody else there could be other moral
emotions that are important too like
indignation like or that sense of
repugnance that you felt you know when
thinking about Conte and his dismissal
of the emotions right maybe that that
sense of repugnance is a moral emotion
something that should guide us the
second thing is if you know nothing's
with care emotion is going to be
respected rather than dismissed in the
process of gaining moral understandings
so what this means is not just that well
we've got emotions or something like
that but that emotions would be actually
used as a guide for moral
decision-making which is pretty big
that's definitely going against McCann
to say and that would even go against
what Bentham is say and you know think
about other people we discussed Plato
that we're going after Plato is saying I
leave it up to you though as we go
through it whether that would be against
what Aristotle is saying maybe not but
that we'll have to explore a little bit
a little bit later